c'est confère une interview par amour
ça bouge et bruno chaillol zut alors par
l'amour sophie thalmann seriez vous
prête à arrêter la télé
bah si on me demande s agirait que c'est
qu'on n'est pas forcément moins deux
mois ça ferait réfléchir paramo seriez
vous prête à quitter la france pour vous
existez au paraguay
c'est peut-être pourquoi pas ouais ça
pourquoi pas par amour auriez vous
recours à la chirurgie esthétique
mais là encore je dirais la même chose
si on me demande s'ils vont changer leur
pas que ce soit ouais c'est qu'on n'aime
pas quand je suis par amour est ce que
vous accepteriez de vivre à trois avec
sa maîtresse surtout pas tu partages pas
par amour ou est ce que vous seriez
prête à aller tous les samedis soir dans
un club échangiste encore mois bon c'est
par là bas mono
quand on aime vraiment quelqu'un même
agrément quelqu'un on se laisse maquée
par la personne voit la femme ou homme
voilà tu serais par un tatouage pour un
mec assis ça on voit ici la fait faire
un d'autres 9 avant que ce trio fille de
se faire tatouer toi no vacancy
un coeur brisé parce que je le demande à
tout dans sa défense lors l on passe
tout sur la même partie du corps elles
le savent est le bon dans le bon je
continue est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à devenir son esclave sexuelle est
marrant quand même est-ce que par amour
ou seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sales c'est la question
de clotilde courau accusés ils vous
regardent souvent elle m'a souvent posé
cette question là et je lui dis non un
moment
ouais est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à prendre 20 kg si dame les rues
basses ouais ça sur une machine faudrait
que je me serais d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
ne plus jamais faire l'amour parce qu'il
serait devenu impuissant dans un
accident de deltaplane imagine bien
impuissant et déjà la puissance la
première goût du god we trust
ceci l'a quand même
ouais ouais je vais dire oui ça sera
double pas qu'il devienne un puissant
quand même bien est-ce que par un
nouveau vous seriez prêtre ne jamais
avoir d'enfant car il veut rester votre
seul enfant pire de tous les pires là
est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à arrêter de fumer
est-ce que par amour ou soyez prêtes à
fumer de l'aveu fouet with mais à vous
l'aimez vraiment alors uniquement parce
que j'ai jamais ni cigarette dans la
bouche c'est parce que dit xavier
sophie dahl la tête des vomissements
l'envers du diabète